the mall is with us in New York I am all
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
how are you better than I deserve what's
up well I'm 35 years old I work as an RN
and I just I started this job like three
months ago
and like a couple weeks ago I had a
accident where I broke my ankle my right
ankle and I couldn't drive and my job
I'm doing insurance so I go to people's
houses I Drive so I I haven't been going
to work and the doctor said you know in
order for my injuries to heal itself I'm
gonna be half I'm gonna have to be out
of work for a couple months like two
more months and my job since it is a new
job they're thinking about letting me go
I've been working as a nurse for six
years I haven't saved anything I'm in
debt I don't know what to do
Sonne you broke your foot yes I broke my
foot yeah how um it was just um I turned
the wrong way it was a weird accident
and the doctor says you can't be on your
feet for six more for four months for
three months or what yeah I'm wearing a
cast right now so I can't drive it's my
right foot yeah so and my job is
thinking about letting me go because I
don't qualify for FMLA why did you why
did you go take this job in insurance
when you're a nurse
because I like that it's remote I don't
really like patient contact that much it
either goes to people to help you to
assess them so it's kind of like oh so
you're acting as a nurse for the
insurance company right yeah so you're
doing medicals okay hmm so I I'm not a
doctor but I've never known anybody to
be in a cast with a break like you're
describing for
three months I suspect you'll be in a
walking boot soon wouldn't you yeah yeah
this week I'm hoping to get a next week
actually I'm hoping that they're gonna
put me in a walking board because it's
been like almost like both my foot like
as a fist so I'm hoping like next week
they're gonna put me in the walking boot
but still she doesn't want me to be
driving the doctor but I don't know but
you're single then you have no means of
supporting yourself I have a baby I have
a one-year-old right now but I'm a
single mom yeah so how would you support
yourself if you don't work how would you
eat well I'm gonna have to go back to
work but like this job paid well so I
was making like I'm making like I have a
monster for a year but it's like net I
would be bringing home like 58 a year 68
58 58 as a nurse that's not right no
it's okay but it ain't great it's not
that yes that well it's not okay so what
so you're gonna lose this job what are
you gonna do I'm gonna have to find
another job
yep I have a lot of debt I have student
loans I have a car loan I haven't it's
just like it's very hard for me to like
I trade a budget every month but it just
doesn't work for me like I don't know
where my money goes sometimes mm-hmm
okay well the first thing we have to do
just get some money coming in to eat
with to solve the overall problem okay
then once you've got money coming in to
eat with then the bad news is you're a
nurse the great news is you're a nurse
which means you can work all the time do
you have anyone in your area that's
family that can support you by helping
to keep your kid a little bit yes
because you're only working 30 to 40
hours a week right now you're not making
but that kind of money is a nurse in the
New Jersey area or New York area I mean
that's just--that's
you have the ability to make almost
double that in that area with that
degree and so I've just got to get your
income
and then get you organized and make the
money that you have coming in behave
you've been us in a situation where
stuff has happened to you for a long
time and this is your moment where you
reach the point you say now I'm going to
happen to stuff instead of stuff
happening to me that years that I broke
my foot was the year I changed my life
because I decided I was going to make my
career decisions I'm going to make my
money behave I'm going to work hard I'm
going to be a grown-up I'm not going to
be impulsive
that's your year this year art okay
mm-hmm that's you yeah how old are you
28
no I'm 35 35 okay all right
this is your year yeah it's the year
everything changes it has to be because
what you've been doing for a decade
hadn't been working correct absolutely
yeah so it's time to get mad enough to
change some stuff and get on top of it
instead of it being on top of you and so
you're gonna work like a maniac a lot
and all the time too much it's gonna
scare you you work so much but you're
gonna make more money than you've ever
made in your life and you're gonna start
cleaning up some of this mess that is a
your debt and you're gonna live on a
budget where you make every single
dollar bark and behave as if it was a
private and you were the general in the
military mm-hmm you can do it you can do
it this is what you have to do I'm gonna
put you through Financial Peace
University or nine week class and put
you into the one-year membership to show
you how to do every bit of this but
kiddo
you got to do it I can't do it for you
you got to believe that if you impact
this stuff you know I I just tried the
budget and it hasn't worked that doesn't
you can't say that anymore every
freaking dollar is going to do what I
tell it to that's the way your voice
starts to sound now you got to change
that that's what you got to do so you
hold on I'll have Kelley pick up and
we'll get you signed up for that and
we'll get this working so thanks for the
call